[Music]
five undocumented immigrants have filed
lawsuits against ice
after their failure to provide them with
covet 19 booster shots while they were
awaiting deportation in the detention
center what the [ __ ] can you say one
more time i like to read a headline and
go
i know what sign i'm on
i don't know what's up i don't know
either yeah i said these one more time
these guys are illegal immigrants they
got caught for something they're not
spent i was trying to find out what the
hell they did but they're basically in
the detention center awaiting
deportation they're going to get sent
back to their country so they already
got their full vaccination they're
waiting for their booster shots while
they're in there they're around a lot of
people with kovid and now they're suing
ice for not giving them the booster shot
wow i unfortunately know what side i'm
on really what side send them home it's
not so much send them home but it's it's
hard to uh
when you're already in a deportation
center it's because you're not a person
of that country if you will that's right
where my mind went to so to like file a
lawsuit using the laws of that country
like they don't seem like they work in
your favor i'm not saying it's like a
good situation but it doesn't seem like
that would make sense because my mind
goes to depends on the state i think i
don't mean i don't know this might be a
federal thing but like let's say for
example
in california i go to your house right
i rob your house if you blast my ass
i'm dead my family can still come and
sue you
even though i perpetrated you first but
in another state like texas that's not
gonna fly one of these guys is in cali
so it's it's just i don't know it could
be
a human rights violation which is more
of an international law thing that's
what i was thinking too yeah
i would say i was thinking the safest
answer that doesn't cancel me
and i would say that
they would they should first see
if making out with each other is going
to get them covered i was not i was not
and if they wanted a vote booster shot
if they wanted that's actually what i
was thinking
everyone already had covid why didn't
they just [ __ ] get kovit from them
and that's their booster shot does it
say what and you know what's inside
then when i clicked the link for the
reason it led to an unsafe page
and you know what's so sketchy about
this like going back to the human rights
issue
um remember when like kovid was first
popping
like uh they were like oh no
there's coveted in the in the jails
um
we gotta start letting them out because
they're in constant danger right so
all the inmates of course are gonna play
on top of that so they're just all given
each other they were like licking the
same [ __ ] towels you could all get
let out right they can all get let out
because they know what the rule is and
then okay cool so that's the rule then
i'll just play the game this way
so it's just it's just tricky i got a
question what happened to all the
remember when code first landed and
we're all at jk and we're talking about
how there's people in china who are
collapsing on the street there's videos
of people collapsing the street yeah
nobody did that over here it's
propaganda dude yeah what what covenant
did we get cause people weren't
collapsing on the street people died
obviously did we get a weaker strain or
what there were a lot of fake videos
yeah there was there was a lot a lot of
them got debunked that those weren't
really covered people there was a there
was a video of a bus driver that just
was violently vomiting gallons of blood
and that was a coveted video back in the
beginning yeah
and they realized it was
gastrointestinal rupturing yeah nobody
knew yet totally remember when they were
showing all the stuff in new york and
how that [ __ ] was going crazy and we
thought la was gonna be like that and
there was like a mass grave and all that
and then there's no talks about it like
it's just
done yeah i think people are just over
it yeah now they are yeah they took but
do people have amnesia or some [ __ ]
because well there's definitely some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] new york i remember like
some some corner trucks and like a bunch
of bodies and those things and like all
that but yeah like you said it didn't
come
it didn't really happen in l.a the same
way it also hit everybody super hard
initially right as far as like what we
knew of what it was and it was really
scary at that time i think media was
just mad irresponsible and just letting
every sensationalist graphic because he
gives all the ground through yeah
because we were all glued to our tvs
that was when they were probably making
the most money oh hell yeah dude and
also because we couldn't do anything but
watch the exactly and we we need an
answer so we're like we trust the media
as far as what they're going to tell us
media's [ __ ] up because they don't
even retract their statements they just
[ __ ] bury it like there's news clips
going on
showing everyone how they were like yeah
the vaccine if you get it you're not
going to get covered you'll be safe you
could walk out to the stroke go get
vaccinated
a bunch everyone said that and then
now they're retracting it and everyone
knows like you could still get covet
even if if you have the best then people
are like they'll say like everyone
everyone knows it's about reducing the
amount of people go to the hospital i'm
like no that's not what they said that's
the [ __ ] i'm saying i know that that's
what they're saying now if they just if
they just took the blame in a little bit
it would have been a lot easier just
said we were wrong a couple exactly and
others like when you hear people that
are in the science community they will
say that they'll be like yo like we
didn't know we're figuring it out
and how they're right this time like
what's the basis of how they're you know
what's weird
okay so right now they're like trying to
cancel joe rogan right and they're
calling him misinformation but isn't it
information is isn't it is it a mystery
isn't it is that way better that's how
he gets checks man because like if
they're telling him that he can't get it
wrong
but they're doing the same thing and
they gotta be [ __ ] perfect so aren't
they misinforming too but they're who
they're blaming they're blaming joe
rogan because he's the guy who's getting
way more views significantly more views
and way more traction than any of these
uh mass media outlets did you see the
the
the reporter who just called out one of
the people at the state department the
state department guy was like hey we
think that all this is going to happen
with ukraine
and then the report is like giving you
evidence and he's like yeah the evidence
is i'm telling you
oh
[ __ ] yeah bro it's crazy we should watch
this video i'll find it for you what the
[ __ ]
they just don't give a [ __ ] anymore no
and that's just like you know weapons
mass destruction like all the [ __ ]
hell dude even just saying that like
assad was gassing his own people now
there's a lot of evidence that that
never happened so it's just it's it's
not what they tell us right it's what we
find out later now it seems like who is
who is allowed to have to say their
perspectives only because like you know
even here right like i mean we are a
news channel even though we're a bunch
of [ __ ] idiots it's like we are
trying to report things i'm a [ __ ] not
an idiot and we're okay well we're
trying to we're still trying to discuss
news in a comedic way but at least
the crazy thing is it's like
you know they have a perspective and if
you challenge that perspective you're
all of a sudden just written off in
cancer conspiracy theories but what
blows my mind is like if you said these
things in the beginning of the pandemic
if you said uh it could be a lab leak it
you know the vaccine probably might not
work and it might not make you
completely immune if you said any of
those things right what ended up
happening was social media will kick you
off social media will ban you social
media will say you're spreading [ __ ]
false information
now it's actually true information your
own social media friends will cancel you
too and your social media friends are
like you're a [ __ ] anti-vaccine
whatever whatever and it's like dude
let's have a conversation like why can't
you talk about this stuff and if you
don't talk about it then you don't know
if it's really right or wrong and then
when all those people got cancelled for
it violating that [ __ ] in the past
they're not getting their accounts back
no no yeah so it's like why are why is
the news allowed to [ __ ] up multiple
times and then like social media people
aren't well they're really trying trees
like 80 it's like uh did you see the um
olympic torch lighting no so the um so
because they laid it with the mask on or
something no they had a freaking uh
they uh the the last person to light
torch is always like a spectacle like oh
who's gonna be the person so uh they had
um a uyghur person do it no they didn't
yeah that's amazing yeah in china and so
like as a as a prop again the way of
china saying see
yeah we're good and then and then nbc
was reporting on it and the nbc reporter
who's [ __ ] obviously like you know in
in cahoots with this whole thing goes
see that's a slam dunk in the face of
anyone who said china was like pressing
and like yeah it's so heinous it's like
insane that they were actually armenian
china bought out art media for sure for
sure what do you think anthony china
pretty much anthony hey china didn't
tell us about kobe until what march
right yeah wasn't that proven yeah but i
was sick in february and that was
probably called me too bro they had the
first case in january
that's the crazy part is like people are
just discussing facts or just you know
stuff we know now even even the
demonstration of the uyghur lighting the
torch like even that would have been
okay that is what it is but the way that
the nbc anchor she goes see that's a
slam dunk in the face like you just made
obviously see not china's fault uh
snbc's fault see we don't know it's very
complex out there that's true
it's complex
like that's it's just like now it just
feels like okay come on guys this
chick's bought out dude yeah it could
have been a thing but yeah i don't know
anyone else just bought it on this room
keep going
anthony has some interesting opinions
about taiwan i'm up for sale
oh yeah anthony the only reason why
we're against cnn 7 is because we're a
news show okay so i understand how we
have our sentiment you know what i mean
and i just want the people to know that
we're we're actually trustworthy i don't
know any millennial or gen z or whatever
watches cnn or any of the alphabet
medias i watch cnn it's all the boomers
really yeah that i'm aware of it's a lot
of boomers i mean there's a lot of
people my age too who are bored at home
and they smoke weed and they watch msnbc
every night or fox news or whatever the
[ __ ] but yeah it's mostly boomers i
don't know anybody our age who watches
fox news actually yeah it's kind of
weird huh should we start watching it
just to like just get our fingers on the
pulse a little bit yeah because whenever
i watch it i'm like who's watching this
stuff and who believes it and because i
don't know anyone here at least that
cares about it or watches they all agree
on the same [ __ ] it's just they say it
different ways it's so [ __ ]
fascinating
no don't they say it the same way well
most of the time they do yeah they
always use the same catch phrases and
the same well especially it's especially
when they agree right but the fox news
guys will will say the same thing about
about whatever topic it is but they just
word it differently it's [ __ ]
interesting yeah yeah it's all much
gymnastics that they're playing around
yeah it's like no no no it's like you
know russia isn't that you know
you know trump isn't affiliated with
russia
but russia's [ __ ] up because of this
that this that it's just the same
talking you're just gymnasticking a
different way it's it's interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you